[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce tout premier set
8 sport de la saison le magazine est
consacrée comme vous le savez à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti à pour le sommaire rugby
versailles a débuté sa saison en
fédérale 2 par une défaite contre marco
à domicile le score est sévère les
plaisirs oies se sont inclinés 51 à 13
les détails dans ce magazine football le
psg a dévoilé vendredi dernier les
contours de son futur centre
d'entraînement à poissy le complexe
comprendra notamment 17 terrains de
football et un stade de 5000 places au
portage à suivre gough la super star
tiger woods va revenir au golf national
24 ans après son dernier passage
le golfeur a été sélectionnée pour faire
partie de la sélection américaine
pendant la ryder cup 2018 coup de
projecteur dans ce set 8 sport
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
rugby ont joué ce week-end le premier
match du championnat de fédérale 2 pour
sa deuxième saison consécutive dans
cette division plaisir a raté son entrée
en lice les pzero a pas encore prêt à
physiquement et tactiquement se sont
lourdement inclinés à domicile contre le
marcquois rugby sur le score de 51 à 13
des images de nicolas d'henry premier
match et première défaite pour plaisir
en fédérale 2 ce dimanche 9 septembre
les jaune et bleu n'ont pas réussi à
rivaliser avec le marcquois rugby dans
leur stade
le score est sans appel à 51,13 quand on
maîtrise aussi peu de chose à un moment
donné la sanction est un peu obligatoire
et
notamment les trois quatre premiers
essais comprends c'est que des fautes de
notre part que l'adversaire va utilise à
fond voilà donc un problème c'est
logique
au total les visiteurs ont inscrit huit
essais dont cinq en deuxième période
une faillite défensive qui s'explique
principalement par une reprise tardive
des entraînements pour une partie du
groupe
c'est vrai que par rapport à ces grosses
écuries qui ont certainement des moyens
différents des nôtres ils ont repris
l'entraînement beaucoup plus tôt que
nous c'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le
jeu est beaucoup plus vils et de leur
côté quoi on est sur un groupe qui bouge
à postales et des garçons qui nous ont
rejoints les automatismes sont pas là
les repères de chaussures pas encore là
voilà on va travailler tous ensemble
pour essayer d'améliorer tout ça avec ce
résultat plaisir pointe à la dernière
place du championnat de fédérale 2 pour
ne pas se mettre en difficulté dans la
course au maintien
une réaction des plaisirs aux est
attendu dès le dimanche 11 septembre
face à gennevillois en football on
jouait ce week-end le port est la
première journée du championnat de d1 de
district guyancourt débute par un match
nul contre gargenville score final un
but partout même résultat pur plaisir
sur le terrain de sartrouville de son
côté à maurepas n'a fait qu'une bouchée
de montesson en s'imposant 6 1 à
l'extérieur résultat qui leur permet de
prendre la tête du championnat enfin le
chesnay arrache le nul 3 partout sur le
terrain de houille et le fc mantois et
hardricourt se neutralisent 2 buts
partout la 2e journée du championnat
sera programmée le 23 septembre prochain
on joue également sur les terrains de
national troyes versailles qui
enregistre au mercato l'arrivée de
l'ancien gardien du rc lens se charles
itandje réalisé une belle prestation sur
son terrain en s'imposant 2 buts à 1
dans un derby vinoy contre les murs au
résultat qui permet au versailles et de
grimper à la 6e place du classement avec
un bilan de deux victoires un nul et une
défaite prochain match le samedi 22
septembre contre le blanc mesnil
on continue à parler football les
seniors de l'étoile sportive de trappes
brille en ce début de saison de r3 ce
week-end les trappistes se sont imposés
1 à 0 à domicile contre boulogne
billancourt leur deuxième victoire de la
saison deux matches disputés des
résultats qui permettent au club
d'occuper la deuxième place du
classement pour nous parler de cette
très bonne dynamique nous recevons sur
ce plateau le président a dit rezaï
guessoum ainsi que le nouvel entraîneur
du club des seniors hicham el
dit bonjour bonsoir bonsoir alors c'est
attendu ses deux victoires en deux
matches attendu pas forcément mais on a
tout fait pour en tout cas
et je voulais revenir sur le projet qui
a été établie à la base dès le mois de
décembre où les démarches ont été
effectuées auprès du club de trappes qui
à fait nécessaire pour préparer ce
championnat même si on est dans le
concret à l'heure actuelle avec deux
victoires notre actif tout ce projet la
haye a commencé a débuté au mois de
septembre avec l'accord du club où
j'étais auparavant et je les remercie
pour ça déjà andy est en contact avec
tard depuis le mois de septembre de
l'année dernière six chevaux en décembre
de la noix de décembre l'année dernière
exactement tout ça en accord avec le
club où j'étais donc ville d'eysines
alors merci pour ça aussi
donc tout a été préparé en amont
notamment au niveau du staff technique
du recrutement des moyens ont été mis à
ma disposition notamment en termes
d'infrastructures matérielles ou autre
et tout ça nous a permis de bien
travailler dans des bonnes conditions
sereinement et de pouvoir débuter le
championnat de manière plutôt efficace
pourquoi avez vous choisi cet entraîneur
dé rezak avant tout dire bonjour aux
michael et puis
on est super contents que hicham rejoint
le club
donc c'était prévu donc on était une
première partie jusqu'à la trêve
et puis à la trêve on s'est aperçu qu'il
fallait redonner un un nouveau projet à
notre catégorie senior et puis déjà et
shine était déjà un peu connue du club
il y avait déjà à l'époque des
discussions avec mon prédécesseur moussa
fall rabat oui ça s'était pas fait et
puis là on s'est rapproché de hicham il
semblait que il fallait reconstruire un
vrai projet pour les seniors donnait
insuffle un peu plus nouveau une
jeunesse et donc hicham a accepté de
rejoindre l'étoile sportive de trappes
avec un projet vraiment un projet qui
nous voilà on est on est très contents
de ce projet là est justement le projet
quelle est votre philosophie de jeu on
sait que en général tu rates n'aime pas
prendre de but
cette année apparemment ça semble bien
parti un seul but en deux matches c'est
un peu votre philosophie ou pas du tout
au delà d'être une philosophie le plus
important ça a été de mettre des
fondations au niveau de l'aspect
défensif notamment tactique d'avoir un
bloc très organisé très compact un
penseur du mont prend pas de but on est
sûr de ne pas perdre un match et en plus
de ça on a eu on a eu l'efficacité est
venu se joindre ce qui a fait par la
suite que sur les deux matches qu'on a
effectué avec un bloc solide compacte et
l'efficacité derrière on me sort avec
deux victoires président vous êtes
actuellement deuxième du championnat est
ce que ça sera la place de trappes à la
fin de la saison
on le sait c'est l'objectif on le fait
alors on va dire que c'est un peu trop
tôt de donner des objectifs à richard
nous
seul objectif que nous abandonnent à
hicham c'est de poursuivre son projet
est ambitieux mais qui est possible
avant tout la devise qu'on a au club
c'est chaque entraîneur qui arrive c'est
le premier objectif qu'ils ont c'est de
maintenir l'équipe ils ont du temps pour
travailler
si à la fin de saison on a une montée
par un bravo aïcha mme bravo au club et
c'est une descente par contre s'il ya
une descente bon chien connaît le petit
duc éducateurs que connaît codé ce qui
se passe quand il ya une descente on le
souhaite pas mais je pour moi il y avait
ça semble bien parti en 13e victoire en
deux matches il n'y a pas de problème il
a du temps pour travailler avec son dock
son groupe
le club lui mettra les moyens qu'il
faudra donc voilà alors nous allons
maintenant parler de l'effet coupe du
monde suite à la victoire de l'équipe de
france en russie il devrait y avoir
entre 20 et 30 % de licenciés en plus
dans les yvelines sont les premiers
chiffres nous sommes allés du côté de
voisins-le-bretonneux lors d'un stage de
pré-saison et la passion bleus étaient
bien présentes on écoute les réactions
d'ivoire c'est la folie s'était trouvé
ça fait plaisir d'avoir une deuxième
étoile
ils jouent bien ils s'entendent bien
histoire mais il était très fort pendant
la coupe du monde donc ça m'a donné
encore plus envie d de jouer au foot pas
ça me donne envie parce que
on a fait la fête toute la soirée on
s'est couchés tard on a regardé le match
qu'à 2 quand j'ai vu qu'il y ait même
pas pu marquer des buts je m'indigne un
vélo route par meego l'horizon j'aime
bien comment sont utilisés les mêmes
outremont témoin abderrazak guessoum est
ce que vous sentez cet engouement chez
les plus jeunes à trappes également ce
que j'avais vu la réserve autonome et
quelques kilomètres plus loin ce qu'il
ya le même engouement
oui bien sûr parce que la chose que je
peux vous dire on a on a entamé samedi
dernier notre première séance de la
rentrée en terme d'inscriptions et là on
a des chiffres qui sont à peu près entre
15 et 20 % d'augmentation
on est actuellement entre 750 et 800
licenciés depuis samedi
que dire combien nous étions mis 53
licenciés joueurs et donc la dépasser ce
chiffre largement mais voilà ça nous
pose
là par contre est une réflexion à avoir
parce qu'en termes de structure en terme
de deux vestiaires et où on peut pas
vraiment accueillir tout le monde
donc là il y aura des positions à
prendre sur certaines catégories déjà
sur des catégories u17 u19 et j'ai la
catégorie h&m en seniors c'est presque
bouclé un déjà là ce serait plutôt sur
des écoles de foot qu'on va continuer à
prendre des inscriptions mais il y aura
des positions à prendre parce que sinon
on va être débordée janot interdit est
ce que vous sentez aussi cette passion
chez les plus grands là on a vu les
jeunes mais ce que chez les seniors il
ya aussi cet engouement là bien sûr bien
sûr qu'il vienne avec + voit le sourire
à l'entraînement par exemple bien sûr ça
se fédérateur surtout quand on revient
avec une coupe du monde on n'a pas
oublié 98 là ça recommence et je rejoins
le président sur le problème
d'infrastructures qui suit derrière
parce que c'est bien beau d'accueillir
beaucoup plus de licenciés mais dans
quelles conditions dans quelle manière
de travailler et quand on voit aussi au
niveau des emplois c'est eux qui sont
partis ou quoi ça devient compliqué à
gérer pour les quarts merci à tous les
deux dépassé sur ce canton continuera à
suivre avec attention les résultats de
trappes cette saison évidemment et on
vous souhaite évidemment terminer le
plus haut possible au classement
on sent maintenant la direction de
poissy dans ce magazine le paris saint
germain et le maire de la commune karl
olive
on a présenté vendredi dernier le futur
centre d'entraînement ultra-moderne du
club un projet d'envergure digne des
grands standards européens avec
notamment 17 terrains de football et un
stade de 5000 places un montage de jus
la grande ville
le futur centre d'entraînement du psg se
dévoilent souvent 17 septembre à poissy
la direction parisienne a présenté les
contours du site de 74 hectares qui sera
implanté sur la commune à 25 minutes du
parc des princes 1 on y retrouvera
notamment 17 terrains de football un
dojo et un terrain de handball la
recherche du paris saint germain
aujourd'hui c'est de recréer un lien
avec l'ensemble de ses activités
sportives aujourd'hui nous sommes est
allé sur le territoire parce qu'il ya
une histoire qui s'inscrit de cette
manière là donc on voulait c'est la
première fois que le toutes les
activités sportives du paris saint
germain pour pouvoir s'implanter sur un
même lieu
la livraison programmée à l'été 2000 21
prévoit également l'implantation d'un
stade de football de 5000 places il y
aura les féminines
il y aura l'équipe réserve les
professionnels vont pouvoir l'utiliser
également de temps en temps il y aura
l'association et d'autres peut-être gens
du territoire qui pourront occuper et
utiliser ce stade le début des travaux
est programmé pour l'été 2010 9 coût
total de l'opération plus de 220
millions d'euros entièrement financés
par le psg
le prix du transfert du brésilien neymar
dans le club de la capitale un mot de
golf à présent la ryder cup c'est dans
deux semaines le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines est prêt à
accueillir soixante mille spectateurs
par jour et surtout les meilleurs
golfeurs mondiaux dans l'équipe
américaine on retrouvera notamment un
certain à tiger woods la superstar du
golf mondial n'avait plus participé à la
compétition depuis 2012 des images de à
patrick jacques de dixmude à un petit
robot lf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le capitaine
de la sélection américaine jim furyk a
décidé de sélectionner tiger woods
l'homme aux 14 tournois du grand chelem
pour la ryder cup 2018 fin septembre une
invitation attendu après le bel été du
golfeur sur les meilleurs tournois
mondiaux
il finit fille née dans l'est dans les
six premiers à l'open britannique il est
deuxième à lui à ce budget il est
toujours devant quand on donne et agger
il revient aux affaires en plus on sort
un joueur en tout cas il paraît beaucoup
plus détendue beaucoup plus ouvert on
sent un joueur qui est qui et qui moi
qui ait moins de tournées vers lui un
peu plus vers les autres et je pense que
ça a dû penchés également dans la
balance dans le dans le choix du du
capitaine américain tiger woods le golf
national ce n'est pas une première le
golfeur avait participé aux championnats
du monde amateurs en 1994 sur le
parcours de l'albatros avec ip
américaine avait gagné à le score par
équipes mais il n'avait pas finir les
premiers méfaits
voilà un beau tournoi mais pas fini
premiers apprenez en individuel au-delà
de l'aspect sportif la venue du golfeur
de 42 ans absent d'une ryder cup depuis
2012 devrait doper les audiences sur le
circuit américain le nombre de
téléspectateurs et multiplier par deux
camps le tigre est sur le grill qu'on le
voit sur les tournois qui joue sur
lesquels il se remet en forme
le dernier
la speed g kiwi fini deuxième où ils ont
battu tous les records d'audience
tiger woods internationale c'est un rêve
je pense et on pouvait pas rêver mieux
si les statistiques médiatiques sont du
côté de tiger woods sur le terrain la
ryder cup ne sourit pas aux golfeurs en
sept participations le sportif ne l'a
remporté qu'une seule fois en 1999
l'équipe a mérité américaine sera
évidemment redoutable tigerwoods mais la
sélection européenne paraît également à
bien armés on connaît déjà les douze
noms qui seront présents golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 28 au 30
septembre prochain on retrouvera
notamment des joueurs d'expérience comme
le golfeur italien francesco molinari
l'anglais justin rose et le nord
irlandais rory mcilroy qui a déjà
participé à quatre éditions
on retrouvera également des novices
comme l'anglais tommy fleetwood ainsi
que le suédois alexis noren finck
vainqueur du dernier open de france
du côté des invitations le capitaine
thomas ce but on a décidé de retenir
quatre golfeurs d'expérience avec les
anglais pollack asie et ian poulter le
suédois henrik stenson et l'espagnol
sergio garcia qui honorera sa 9e
sélection
les premiers entraînements sont
programmés le mardi 25 septembre au golf
national
on ouvre une page automobile et une very
well natacha grzeskowiak va tenter de
participer à la sixième édition du
trophée roses des zones en avril 2019
une course d'orientation en 4/4
exclusivement féminine qui se déroulent
dans des déserts argentin une aventure
qu'elle va partager avec son ami à
sakina alain nous avons le plaisir de
les recevoir sur ce plateau ce soir
bonsoir
non ça alors pourquoi avez vous décidé
de vous lancer dans cette aventure eh
ben c'est plutôt ça qui n'a en fait qui
m'a proposé de me lancer dans cette
aventure avec elle c'est une aventure
humaine mais surtout sportive solidaire
féminine tout ce qu'on aime
et puis c'est un super c'était le moyen
en fait de finir avec notre grande
amitié qui dure voilà depuis neuf ans et
donc c'est un super projet qu'on avait
envie de mener ensemble et on contribue
justement de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
tout à fait et
et donc depuis on ne s'est pas lâché
alors vous êtes des aventures dans l'âme
ou pas du tout on aime l'aventuré on
aime les voyages en et mes découvertes
aventurière dans l'âme c'est peut-être
un peu fort mais oui la sq ont cherché
de l' aventure clairement ouais on aime
les voyages et puis après ça dépend de
la conception je pense de chacun pour
moi la vie est tout le temps une
aventure tous les jours pas besoin
d'aller forcément à des à des milliers
de kilomètres voilà je trouve qu'au
quotidien je mène déjà des choses très
aventurière alors on parlait de voyage
est ce que vous êtes déjà partis en
argentine alors ne pas pour ma part non
plus mais on a hâte parce que vous avez
appréhendé
on a les déserts argentan non seulement
on est assez sereine sereine et plus tôt
même très curieuse et plutôt pressés de
découvrir des paysages que on imagine
fabuleux de parce qu'on on en voit dans
les dents les les images déjà vues
donc il y aura des dunes des canyon est
ce que vous êtes entraînés pour cette
épreuve
on va s'entraîner spécifiquement avec
une femme se soit encore là encore c'est
en avril 2019 qu'on a un peu de temps
mais la formation mécanique ça arrivera
dans quelques mois oui formation
mécanique dans quelques mois et puis
après au niveau du sport on est quand
même relativement sportifs toutes les
deux on aime bien courir et puis comme
tout pour moi je suis en salle de sport
natacha aime beaucoup la danse aussi ses
grandes passions mois le cheval corps
voilà donc no soul mekanik pour
l'instant pas encore arrivé voilà une
formation si justement l'art et la
mécanique
alors ton m'a pas du tout parce que
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup au contraire la
mécanique
enfin j'aime beaucoup l'automobile j'ai
toujours été très attiré par par les
voitures partout voilà après c'était
servira aussi dans la vie c'est toujours
utile de savoir changer une roue donc
c'est une bonne chose à apprendre des
premiers à ce que vous allez tester
toutes les deux peut-être en binôme
aussi avant de partir sur l'épreuve on
sait que forcément
voilà une entraide avant un entraînement
à 2 sera peut-être nécessaire
forcément dans les dunes en fait en tant
qu' en tant qu'ami on s'entraide déjà au
quotidien on est toujours
la ligne pour l'autre et même là dans
notre premier travail en recherche des
sponsors
c'est vraiment très prenant et on passe
déjà par des hauts et des bas et on
apprend à se connaître encore mieux
par cette aventure qui n'a pas commencé
en argentine mais qui a déjà commencé
pour nous par la recherche de sponsors
par la communication etc
et puis certaines marques automobiles
con qu'on vise en tant que partenaires
nous propose quand même
enfin on sait qu auprès de leurs causes
leurs concessionnaires en france on peut
déjà essayé certains certains véhicules
donc
donc oui je pense qu'on est ce qu est ce
que vous serez coupé du monde sur ce
mouvement parce qu'on a accompagné quand
même d'une organisation qui nous fait il
ya des vraiment des règles de sécurité
donc on est suivi avec un système de
géolocalisation et tous les soirs on
retrouve un camp avec les autres
participantes
par contre quand on est dans le désert
c'est vraiment nous dans notre véhicule
et on doit s'orienter nous mêmes en fait
c'est avec laquelle vous perdre tout à
fait oui ça c'est un petit peu
inquiétant ans après les faits alors sur
le plan sportif
votre objectif c'est de terminer la
course c'est d'aller le plus haut
possible
alors là sur le plan sportif c'est déjà
de pouvoir partir sur la ligne de départ
c'est notre premier objectif là et
ensuite effectivement une fois entamé la
course
ah oui brandir le trophée ce serait
c'est très l'objectif principal visé un
podium ouais bah oui bien sûr et donc il
faut combien pour partir il en est à
combien actuellement eh bien il faut
environ vingt mille euros c'est une
somme qui est conséquente parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup donc d'organisation
derrière qui nous suit
il ya tout le déplacement en avion etc
la location du véhicule nos formations
et surtout il ya une part qui revient
aux associations et aux populations
locales
on va rencontrer là-bas tout au long de
vos trajets exactement on va aller aider
des enfants des femmes des familles et
donc il ya une partie de ces vingt mille
euros qui vont leur revenir pour les
aider à développer leurs projets et donc
on a choisi de les redistribuer en sous
forme de dons plutôt que sous forme de
fournitures ou de choses plus
matérielles tout simplement pour une
question de logistique parce qu'on
pourra pas tous transportés en avion et
depuis la france et comment on peut
faire pour vous aider
justement à partir en argentine et
sponsorisé tout à fait rentrer en
contact du coup on est tout à fait
accessible à vous pouvez nous retrouver
bas sur les réseaux sociaux donc
instagram facebook voilà grain de sel
sur le nom grande crainte c'est tout à
fait c'est lui notre association
donc vous pouvez nous aider en tant
qu'entreprise sponsors sinon à titre
plus personnel on a aussi une cagnotte
en ligne sur le site lots aso vous
pouvez nous retrouver également sur ce
site voila merci beaucoup pour votre
venue sur ce plateau vont suivre avec
attention votre parcours si vous arrivez
à partir je le rappelle est bon courage
pour la suite
merci beaucoup un mot de boxe à présent
l'élan courtois à marvin à petit de la
team farruggia sera bientôt de retour
sur les rings le boxeur de 27 ans qui
totalise 23 victoires pour un nul et une
défaite tentera de décrocher la ceinture
ebu européenne en décembre prochain
pour cela il combattra lewis ritson chez
lui en angleterre un gros morceau
le britannique est à l'heure actuelle
invaincu en 17 combats et totalise 11 k
o
les peugeot boxer a dès demain la date
exacte du combat sera fixé à dans les
approches un jour on passe maintenant
notre chronique junior notre journaliste
méline coquet nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau alors souvent pour beaucoup
rentrée des classes rime avec reprise
et et sportives pour les enfants et les
adultes les tout petits peuvent ainsi
dépenser mais la mise sur saint quentin
en yvelines de nombreuses associations
proposent des activités
et puisqu'en fait une qu'elle les petits
peuvent commencer le sport des quatre
ans des quatre mois pardon alors si vos
enfants la bougeotte pourquoi ne pas les
inscrire à la baby gym
bien sûr on est loin du sport de haut
niveau mais vos enfants vous quand même
se dépenser c'est surtout un temps de
partage entre les parents et les enfants
élisabeth meilhac a lancé cette activité
à l'association vivre à manille à magny
les hameaux et c'était il ya quarante
ans une activité corporelle mais une
activité aussi sensorielle puisque
l'enfant quand ils arrivent le bébé
puisque on prend les petits à partir de
6 mois une activité qui permet à
l'enfant de pratiquer
des jeux des exercices de motricité qui
vont lui permettre d'évoluer et de
s'éveiller à l'aide de ses parents alors
ça se passe je suis avec les parents
venaient d'entendre mais il ya aussi les
nounous les assistantes maternelles
deux créneaux ont lieu le mardi matin au
gymnase auguste delaune
il faut compter une heure d'activité et
il reste encore de la place
mais ce n'est pas la seule association à
proposer cette activité mélanie oui
alors c'est surtout l'activité la plus
présente pour les tout-petits parce que
la gym on peut la pratiquer avec la smb
baby gym de montigny-le-bretonneux il ya
les bout'choux qui sont accueillis dès
12 mois
la gemme à elle encore mort pacs à lens
a lancé sa section baby gym dès l'âge de
15 mois et l'association gymnastique
volontaire de plaisir accueillait les
petits à partir de 25 mois à vivre
on débute à deux ans donc à 24 mois avec
l'olympique gymnaste et pour les bébés
nageurs mais le nord il y en a qui
aiment beaucoup barboter apparemment ça
rappellerait quand il était dans le
ventre de leur maman on part à montigny
le bretonneux et à guyancourt alors la
première commune propose cette activité
au centre aquatique du lac pour les
petits nez dès cette année les chronos
sont le samedi matin et à guyancourt les
bébés vous dans l'eau dès l'âge de 6
mois
c'est surprenant mais la nuit merci
beaucoup en tout cas on se retrouve le
m'approchant passe maintenant notre page
agents bas
[Musique]
on nous cette page agenda part du
football on jouera ce week-end le
troisième tour de la coupe de france à
cette occasion montigny le bretonneux
qui évolue en deuxième division de
district recevra le club de
choisy-le-roi une équipe de r de trois
divisions au-dessus des signes montrent
un la tâche paraît donc compliqué mais
rien est impossible dans cette coupe de
france où on voit régulièrement des
surprises pour les soutenir la rencontre
est programmée ce dimanche 16 septembre
à 14h30 toujours à montigny le
bretonneux mais cette fois ci en
baseball les cougars joueront ce
week-end en quarts de leur quart de
finale de playoffs de première division
contre les boucaniers de la rochelle un
match ou leasing montain seront favoris
après avoir terminé la phase de
qualification à la troisième place avec
15 victoires en 24 matchs de son côté la
rochelle n'a remporté que six petits
matches cette saison pour se qualifier
ce rendez vous se joue au meilleur des
trois matches des rencontres sont
organisées sur deux jours le samedi et
le dimanche un handball plaisir reprend
le chemin de la nationale 3 ce week-end
pour la première rencontre de
championnat de la saison les plaisirs
war seront montfermeil au gymnase
nicholas l'herbe objectif de cette
saison pour les yvelinois tenter de
faire aussi bien que l'an passé avec une
superbe deuxième place et une montée
pour la nationale 2 manqué en barrages
la rencontre de ce week-end s'annonce
déjà à capitale toujours en bas les
féminines de montigny le bretonneux
joueront leur premier match de la saison
ce week-end contre aux andes du 29 à
l'extérieur la rencontre est programmée
au gymnase le porzou à concarneau le ce
dimanche à 16 heures une victoire
permettrait de lancer la saison des îles
montaigne les objectifs du club sont
élevées une place dans le top 5 en fin
de saison et si possible une remontée
enfin on termine par un rendez vous
insolite ce dimanche au 16 septembre la
parc zoologique de thoiry ouvre ses
portes aux runner pour la première fois
un tracé de 10 km alternant ce sentier
forestier route a été imaginé au sein
même de la structure
les compétiteurs pourront notamment
courir au milieu des animaux dans la
réserve africaine
la compétition est déjà complète les
1500 dos avant tous trouvé preneurs mais
les curieux peuvent venir voir la
compétition sans vie à participer c'est
la fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi prochain pour
un nouveau magazine d'ici là passez une
excellente semaine sportive très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]